why does the earth have to be either
round or flat
what if there could be a happy middle
ground
welcome to your very own polyhedron
earth
what would the earth look like
in what ways would this affect our
planet's gravity
and what impact would this have on the
continents as we know them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth was a polyhedron
polyhedrons come in all shapes and sizes
anything that has multiple faces joined
at their edges can be a polyhedron
picture earth as a six-sided cube or as
a triangular pyramid with four faces
known as a tetrahedron or even two
rectangular pyramids stacked on top of
each other that would be an octahedron
but there could be one polyhedron that
is the best contender for earth's new
shape
an icosahedron
this polyhedron has 20 identical
triangular faces
it could match up perfectly with a map
that provides the most accurate version
of earth when displayed on a
two-dimensional surface
so
if our planet looked like a 20-sided die
what would be the odds that it's
anything like the earth we live on today
wouldn't want to take those odds and if
you're writing without grammarly i'd bet
against you every time
every word i write on what if counts and
we don't leave anything to chance
grammarly premium's bold ai powered
system gives your writing the edge you
need to describe the universe or write
an email it doesn't matter if i'm at
home or on the bus i can always come
across clear and precise
remember it's not just what you say it's
how you say it
keep your voice while writing
confidently with a clear and concise
message with the built-in tone detector
and right now what if viewers can get
twenty percent off grammarly premium at
grammarly.com
what if that's twenty percent off at g r
a m a r l y dot com slash what if
i'd rather take the odds of surviving a
20-sided earth then live without
grammarly
you've probably seen a flat rectangular
map of the earth but what you may not
know is how distorted these maps can be
that's because it's difficult to display
the three-dimensional surface of a
spherical earth onto two dimensions
on these maps greenland often looks
almost as big as the entire continent of
africa
when in reality africa is about 14 times
larger
the fuller projection map also known as
a dimaxian map is a projection of the
earth onto the faces of an icosahedron
impressively this map creates no obvious
distortions of shapes and sizes of land
areas
only life on an icosahedron earth would
be quite distorted
the most dramatic change you'd notice
would be a completely different gravity
than what you have today
gravity is what makes a planet round in
the first place
as it's forming a planet is hot and
composed of molten material
since its gravity pulls equally in all
directions from its center
it eventually takes on the shape of a
sphere
but on a polyhedron earth there would be
an unequal distribution of gravity
only at the direct center of each of the
20 faces would you experience what you
know as normal gravity
as you moved toward the corners of each
face you'd feel the pull of gravity
lessening
let's imagine you weigh 90 kilograms
with earth's current gravity
only at the center of the icosahedron
face would you weigh this much
on the corners you could now find
yourself weighing in at about 58
kilograms
not bad
this unequal pull of gravity would also
make a walk from the center of one face
to its corner feel more like a hike
it would get steeper and steeper as
you'd go along the enormous mountain
corners of our icosahedron planet
naturally this would have a dramatic
effect on earth's oceans
the water would pool toward the center
of each individual face creating vast
bodies of water in the middle of each
this would leave the edges dry and
barren
the same would happen to our atmosphere
you'd find that the edges would provide
minimal protection from the sun but
isolated in the center would be thick
atmospheres capable of preventing
harmful uv radiation from reaching the
surface
the dymaxion map could give the
impression that all the continents would
fit neatly together on an icosahedron
as you can see this new earth would look
very different from the earth you know
northern africa parts of western europe
and the middle east would all exist
together on one triangular face
south america would be divided across
three distinct sides
canada and greenland would form one
giant land mass
and the us on the other hand would
remain largely unchanged
well unchanged might not be the best
choice of words
with all these dramatic shifts in
gravity water locations and the
atmosphere
it would be pretty difficult to
recognize the old continents
earth would now have 20 completely
isolated ecosystems at the center of
each face
within each of them you could find
unique varieties of animals and plants
but you'd have quite an uphill journey
through the extremes of the lifeless
corners of the earth just to get to the
other faces
a flat dymaxion map is meant to present
a more realistic geographic
representation of earth
turn it into a fully three-dimensional
version and it would end up being quite
distorted to say the least
and that's before you see the effect
this would have on the moon
its orbit would be significantly
disrupted by the differences in gravity
between the centers and edges of each
face
eventually this could lead to the moon
crashing into earth
and that would do some damage
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]